The second way to submit assignments is through to
the Udacity site itself. I'm going to walk you through
an example from the advanced operating systems course. As you
can see in this project, questions are being asked directly
in this IDE, I can submit my answers by typing
them in directly here. Then I click the Submit button
to send it through the site. I'll get some feedback
to let me know that my submission was accepted and
to note that my grade will be assigned by a
human being. An important thing to note is that I can
change my answer and resubmit my submission through the site.
The class schedule will tell me up to the minute of
when my submission will be pulled from the site and
graded. I can continue to change my answer and resubmit as
many times as I want up until this deadline. After
the deadline, I can still change my answers and submit them
through the site but they won't go anywhere and no one will be grading
them. Please check with your TA instructor
if you have any questions about these deadlines.